It's a beautiful spring day here in San Francisco.
Perfect time to talk about suicide, really.
Hey everyone, Laci Green here for DNews.
Did you know that suicides peak in the spring?
It's a stable trend that has been tracked
since the 1820s and in dozens of countries
around the world.
The most suicidal month is May, when suicides
spike by up to 50%.
I would have guessed it would be a winter
month but...nope, the winter months actually
have the LOWEST suicide rates.
As for those affected, suicide is most common
amongst those over 65, but for the 15-24 age
group, suicide is the 3rd leading cause of
death.
While women are more likely to have suicidal
*thoughts*, men are most likely to *complete*
a suicide and make up about 80% of cases.
This is attributed to the fact that men are
more likely to use unforgivable means: like
firearms, whereas women are more likely to
overdose or poison themselves.
There are a lot of big questions to untangle
the suicide web in order to effectively prevent
them, and one of them is: why spring?
Why suicides around the world peak in the
spring is actually one of the most studied
questions in psychiatry.
Which makes it even stranger that scientists
still don't have any hard answers.
One of the original theories when this was
first discovered in the 1800s that the spring
brings more sun, and with the sun more feel-good
neurotransmitters like serotonin provide us
with more energy.
But in a depression sufferer, that energy
manifests not with more socializing and time
outdoors -- but as inward aggression and self
harm.
Spring's sun may provide a boost of energy
required to successfully execute a suicide
plan.
While this is an ollllld theory, it's one
that's still around and highly regarded by
scientists.
In fact, the serotonin bit was a more recent
development.
Another leading theory comes down to the relationship
between suicide and inflammation.
What we've already known for awhile is that
there is a strong link between depression
and inflammation -- inflammatory diseases
heighten depression risk more so than other
diseases do.
There are a couple reasons why inflammation
might be higher in the spring -- people tend
to get sick more in the winter (which I did
another DNews on why if you're interested)
and there may be residual inflammation from
those late winter infections.
Another reason is, of course, allergies!
Allergies drive an inflammatory response.
A study at the University of Maryland has
actually found a positive link between high
tree pollen counts with high seasonal suicide
rates.
It's also been found that those who work in
agriculture have even more exaggerated suicide
rates in the spring.
It may very well be in the trees, peeps.
I seem to recall an M. Night Shamalan movie
about something like that?
I think it was called "The Happening".
.....Kind of weird.
Maybe he was onto something.
Thanks for joining me for DNews everyone,
stay safe and healthy.
I've dropped some stuff down below in the
description for anyone out there who may be
having a tough time themselves this spring.
Nobody should have to go it alone, and sometimes
reaching out for help is the bravest thing
you can do to take care of yourself.
I'll see you folks next time.